Hey there, everybody. If you're listening on our podcast or at the internet, there are words in this episode that we have unbeeped. If you prefer a beeped version of the show, you could find that at our website, Thisamericanlife.org. One of our producers here at This American Life, Robyn Semien, wanted to find a New York police officer to talk to for today's program.
大家好。如果您正在通过播客或互联网收听本节目，本期节目中包含我们未经过“哔”声消音处理的词汇。如果您更喜欢消音版，可以在我们的网站 Thisamericanlife.org 上找到。我们《美国生活》的一位制作人罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）想在今天的节目中采访一位纽约警察。
And she spent two weeks calling police union offices in different boroughs. She reached out to crime reporters, you know, a lot of cops. Robyn used to work in a corrections facility in the Bronx, so she knows lots of cops. And finally she managed to convince one of them. She convinced a friend on the NYPD to sit down with her. And the climate for cops in New York right now is so embattled that this officer asked that we not use her name or her voice or say what neighborhood she works in.
她花了两个星期给不同区的警察工会办公室打电话。她联系了犯罪记者，你知道，还有很多警察。罗宾以前在布朗克斯的一家教养机构工作，所以她认识很多警察。最后，她终于说服了其中一位。她劝说了一位纽约警局的朋友与她面对面交谈。目前纽约警察面临的处境非常艰难，因此这位警官要求我们不要使用她的名字或声音，也不要透露她所在的辖区。
We can say that she works in a high crime area with not many white people in it. And she and Robyn sat down to watch the Eric Garner video together. Robyn is black and not a cop. Her police officer friend is white and a cop. Eric Garner, of course, was an unarmed black man who died when a group of NYPD tried to arrest him for allegedly selling loose cigarettes on the street in July. And Robyn wanted to understand what a police officer sees when they watch the video.
我们可以说，她工作的地方是一个犯罪率高、白人居民较少的社区。她和罗宾一起观看了埃里克·加纳（Eric Garner）的视频。罗宾是黑人，不是警察。她的警察朋友是白人，是名警官。埃里克·加纳当然是一位手无寸铁的黑人，他在七月试图因涉嫌在街上非法贩卖散烟而被纽约警局的一群警察逮捕时死亡。罗宾想了解警察在观看这段视频时看到了什么。
Is this good policing, bad policing? Where does this go wrong? What does Eric Garner do right? What does he do wrong? Like, these kinds of questions, basic stuff--
这是好的警务，还是坏的警务？问题出在哪里？埃里克·加纳哪里做得对？哪里做得不对？像这类问题，最基础的东西——
That's Robyn. She says that she and her friend sat down in front of a computer, and they basically just walked through the video, stopping and starting and talking. And her friend told her that at every step, right from the start, Eric Garner seems to be resisting arrest. He is not compliant. He does not produce an ID. He keeps talking and stalling.
那是罗宾。她说她和她的朋友坐在电脑前，基本上就是逐帧回放视频，停顿、开始、交谈。她的朋友告诉她，从一开始的每一步来看，埃里克·加纳似乎都在拒捕。他不配合。他不提供身份证件。他一直在说话并拖延时间。
Even once he's on the ground, there's this five or six seconds where he's laying on his right side. Police go to cuff his left hand. Meanwhile, his right arm is extended on the concrete, his right palm facing up. His fingers are apart. Robyn showed this to me on the video.
即使在他倒地后，还有五六秒钟他侧躺在右侧。警察试图锁住他的左手。与此同时，他的右臂伸在水泥地上，右手掌朝上。他的手指张开。罗宾在视频中向我指出了这一点。
Just watch his right hand. It's face up.
看他的右手。它是掌心向上的。
Put your hand behind your back.
把手放到背后去。
Put your hand behind your back, they say. OK, and it's right at this moment where there's five police officers on him. His hands are spread. She's saying, why isn't he put-- she says to me over and over, why isn't he putting his hand behind his back? See, he's resisting. At that moment, five officers on him, he's on the ground-- yeah, like, I don't see how he could put his hand behind his back if he wanted to.
他们说，把手放到背后去。好吧，就在这一刻，五名警察压在他身上。他的手是摊开的。她不断地跟我说，为什么他不把手……她说，为什么他不把手放到背后？你看，他在反抗。那一刻，五名警察压着他，他躺在地上——是的，我是说，我看不出他如果想把手放到背后该怎么放。
OK, play it again.
好吧，再放一遍。
Yeah, he's down on the ground. He's crawling. His arm is pinned. His right arm is pinned, and then they all pull his arm around and handcuff him.
是的，他躺在地上。他在爬。他的手臂被压住了。他的右臂被压住了，然后他们一起把他的手臂拉过来给他戴上手铐。
So it's just that fast, OK.
所以就是这么快，好吧。
It's that fast. We watched it over and over. She only saw it as him not complying, basically, wrestling and refusing to be arrested. And I can only ever see it, I mean, as the opposite. I can only ever see it as, like, a person who seems thoroughly detained. Like, I'm thinking at this point, it's under control.
就是这么快。我们看了又看。她只看到他不配合，基本上是在扭打和拒绝被捕。而我只能看到相反的一面。我只能看到一个人似乎已经被完全控制住了。我是说，我想在这一点上，情况是可控的。
Why keep applying force?
为什么要继续施加武力？
And she's like, it's clearly not under control and there is more force to be applied.
而她觉得，这显然没有被控制住，还有更多的武力需要施加。
When Eric Garner says over and over, I can't breathe, Robyn sees a man who's dying. Her friend does not. She tells Robyn people say that all the time when they're being arrested. They can't breathe. You're hurting them. It happens all the time. The officer totally understood why the police on the scene did not pay any attention to it.
当埃里克·加纳反复说“我无法呼吸”时，罗宾看到的是一个正在垂死挣扎的人。她的朋友却没有。她告诉罗宾，人们在被捕时总是这么说。他们说无法呼吸，说警察在伤害他们。这经常发生。这位警官完全理解为什么现场的警察没有理会这一点。
And does she understand why you see it the way you do?
那么她理解你为什么那样看吗？
No.
不。
She thinks that when you look at it, you should see it the way she sees it.
她认为当你看着它时，你应该看到她所看到的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
And did it make her mad that you couldn't see it?
你无法看到她所看到的，这让她生气了吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it did.
是的。是的，确实生气了。
Because to her it's obvious.
因为对她来说这显而易见。
Yeah, and that's a very weird feeling to be sitting next to someone-- anyone, let alone a friend-- and to be watching a video and saying, like, don't you see this person is in pain, struggling to communicate? What's odd to me is that now, even after the fact, we know that he really couldn't breathe. And she kind of wouldn't even totally cop to the fact that he was probably telling the truth as we watched the video.
是的，这是一种非常奇怪的感觉，坐在某人——任何人，更不用说是一个朋友——旁边，看着一段视频，然后说，难道你没看到这个人很痛苦，正在努力沟通吗？对我来说奇怪的是，现在，即使事后我们知道他确实无法呼吸，而我们在观看视频时，她甚至几乎不愿意承认他可能说的是真话。
Robyn went into this conversation figuring they would have at least some common ground. But they talked for four hours, and the longer they talked, the more they both realized there was just nothing, just none. Robyn's friend said she did understand why people saw this as a racial incident, but she definitely did not.
罗宾开始这次谈话时，以为他们至少会有一些共同点。但他们谈了四个小时，谈得越久，他们俩越意识到根本没有任何共同点，一点都没有。罗宾的朋友说她确实理解为什么人们将其视为种族事件，但她绝对不这么认为。
When Robyn asked her what should be done now, she didn't think anything should be done. We're doing a good job, she said. Other police have said this, too, and pointed out that New York in particular-- a city of 8.4 million people, 35 thousand officers, guns everywhere, everywhere in our country-- in the last year that's been tallied, 2013, New York officers fired their weapons just 40 times in adversarial conflict-- 40 times.
当罗宾问她现在应该怎么做时，她认为什么都不用做。她说，我们做得很好。其他警察也说过同样的话，并指出特别是纽约——一个拥有840万人口、3.5万名警察、枪支泛滥的城市，在有记录的过去一年（2013年）里，纽约警察在对抗性冲突中只开了40次枪——只有40次。
This is the second week in a row that we're doing a program about how cops see things differently, doing stories about policing and race. And we have two stories for you today. One of them is about a city where things went just terribly between police and black residents. And the other story is about a place that is the opposite, where they seem to be going kind of great, or anyway, things have improved dramatically.
这是我们连续第二周做关于警察如何看待事物的节目，讲述关于治安和种族的故事。今天我们有两个故事。其中一个是关于一个城市，那里的警察和黑人居民之间的关系变得极其糟糕。另一个故事是关于一个相反的地方，那里的情况看起来进展顺利，或者无论如何，情况已经有了显著改善。
And we chose these stories because in both of them, we learned things that we had not heard before anywhere about how much can go wrong, and how it goes wrong when it goes wrong, and about just how rigorous and aggressive and smart police have to be if they want things to go well. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们选择这些故事是因为在两个故事中，我们都学到了一些之前从未听过的事情，关于事情会出错到什么程度，以及当事情出错时是如何出错的，还有关于如果警察想要一切顺利，他们必须表现得多么严谨、积极和聪明。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Inconvenience Store. So the community where policing went so badly is called Miami Gardens. It's a city of about 110,000 people with a lot of crime, a higher murder rate than Chicago or New York or Miami. In fact, it used to be part of Miami-Dade County and broke off in 2003. It became a separate city, started their own police force after that, partly because the Miami-Dade cops hadn't been so responsive to the community.
第一幕，便利店。治安变得如此糟糕的社区叫迈阿密花园（Miami Gardens）。这是一个拥有约11万人口的城市，犯罪率很高，谋杀率高于芝加哥、纽约或迈阿密。事实上，它曾经是迈阿密-戴德县（Miami-Dade County）的一部分，在2003年独立出来。在此之后，它成为了一个独立的城市，建立了他们自己的警察部队，部分原因是迈阿密-戴德的警察对社区的反应不太灵敏。
And at first, apparently, people loved the new cops. Miami Gardens is an overwhelmingly black community. Its leaders are black. They had a black police chief. Residents called the new cops the bumblebees because they seemed to be swarming everywhere and people liked that.
起初，人们似乎很喜欢新警察。迈阿密花园是一个绝大多数为黑人的社区。它的领导人是黑人。他们有一位黑人警察局长。居民们称新警察为“大黄蜂”，因为他们似乎到处都是，人们对此感到高兴。
And, really, it just took a couple years for it to become a total mess, as you'll hear. And the best illustration of how bad it got happened to two men-- the owner of a convenience store called the Quickstop and one of his employees. Miki Meek tells the story.
而且，真的，仅仅过了几年，这里就变得一团糟，正如你即将听到的那样。关于情况有多糟糕，最好的写照发生在两个人身上——一家名为“快停”（Quickstop）便利店的老板和他的一名员工。米基·米克（Miki Meek）讲述了这个故事。
The Quickstop in Miami Gardens is a hangout spot in the poorer part of the city. There's a big parking lot, where groups of men sit on their cars listening to music and smoking cigarettes. A constant stream of customers keeps the front door swinging back and forth. They're stopping in to pick up a bag of chips, some candy, a few beers.
迈阿密花园的“快停”便利店是该市较贫穷地区的一个聚会点。那里有一个很大的停车场，一群男人坐在车上听音乐、抽烟。源源不断的顾客让前门来回摆动。他们停下来买一袋薯片、一些糖果和几罐啤酒。
When I first showed up, it seemed pretty rough. Some of the regulars clearly had mental health problems. There's been a lot of drug arrests in the parking lot. And back in 2008, right after the city launched its new police department, officers stopped by and they talked to the owner of the Quickstop, a guy named Alex Saleh. They asked him if he wanted to partner with the police in a new initiative called The Zero-Tolerance Zone Trespassing Program.
当我第一次到那里时，觉得环境挺混乱的。一些常客显然有心理健康问题。停车场里发生过很多毒品逮捕事件。早在2008年，也就是该市刚成立新警察部门后不久，警察到访并与“快停”的老板亚历克斯·萨利赫（Alex Saleh）交谈。他们问他是否想与警方合作开展一项名为“零容忍区域入侵计划”的新倡议。
You know what, why not? I'm pro-police. I'm pro-cop.
你知道吗，为什么不呢？我支持警察。我支持执法。
Alex says he never had any problems inside his store. But under the program, the police would keep an extra eye on the Quickstop and on the parking lot, and if they thought something was up, they wouldn't have to wait for Alex to phone in a complaint. They could stop and question or apprehend someone if they felt they had cause. So Alex thought--
亚历克斯说他的店里从来没出过问题。但在该计划下，警方会对“快停”和停车场保持额外关注，如果他们认为有情况，他们不必等亚历克斯打电话投诉。如果他们认为有理由，他们就可以拦截并盘问或逮捕某人。所以亚历克斯心想——
We're going to work together, fight crime together. He said, you see the new police department. You're going to be able to build, you know, a great relation with the officers. You know, this sounds great.
我们将一起工作，共同打击犯罪。他说，你看新的警察部门。你将能够与警察建立（你知道的）良好的关系。你知道，这听起来不错。
Alex screwed a metal sign onto the front of his store, declaring it a zero-tolerance zone. He liked how official it looked with the city seal. He felt proud, but then after just a couple weeks, something odd started happening.
亚历克斯在店前钉上了一块金属标志，宣布这是零容忍区域。他喜欢它看起来带上市政府印章的官方感。他感到自豪，但仅仅过了几周，奇怪的事情就开始发生了。
Cops start coming to the parking lot almost every other day. They used to go inside the store and tell the customer while they're paying in the line, excuse me. You, you, and you, come outside. I was like, outside?
警察几乎每隔一天就开始来停车场。他们过去经常走进店里，对正在排队结账的顾客说：打扰一下。你，你，还有你，出来。我当时想，出来？
Alex says he'd be standing right there in the store, right behind the counter, and officers would ignore him and tell his customers to put down their things. Then they'd take the customers outside and line them up against the wall. The customers were always black. The officers were almost always white.
亚历克斯说他会站在店里，柜台后面，而警察会无视他，让他的顾客放下东西。然后他们会把顾客带到外面，让他们靠墙站成一排。顾客总是黑人。警察几乎总是白人。
Sometimes you'd see, like, 10 people against the wall, searching everyone. But I'm confused. Did those guys commit a crime? Did those guys really do something?
有时候你会看到，像10个人靠墙站着，搜查每个人。但我很困惑。这些人犯罪了吗？这些人真的做了什么吗？
And what would you do in that point? You would see them pull customers out of line, and what would you say?
你在那种情况下会怎么做？你会看到他们把顾客从队伍中拉出来，你会说什么？
I told the officers, excuse me. What is this situation? Where's the problem? Can somebody explain to me what is? They said, don't worry about it. That's our job.
我告诉警察，打扰一下。这是什么情况？问题在哪里？有人能向我解释这是怎么回事吗？他们说，别担心。那是我们的工作。
Before long, it wasn't just the customers being questioned. The police started including a guy named Earl. Alex paid him to do odd jobs around the store. One night, right before closing, Alex sent Earl out to the parking lot with a broom and a dustpan. When he didn't come back, Alex want out to check on him.
没过多久，被盘问的就不再只是顾客了。警方开始包括一个叫厄尔（Earl）的人。亚历克斯雇他在店周围做些杂活。一天晚上，快关门前，亚历克斯派厄尔拿着扫帚和簸箕去停车场。当他没回来时，亚历克斯出去查看情况。
I see only the dustpan and the broom. And I don't see Earl.
我只看到了簸箕和扫帚。没看到厄尔。
It wasn't like Earl to walk off the job. The next day when he arrived at the store, Alex asked him about it.
厄尔不是那种擅离职守的人。第二天他来到店里时，亚历克斯问起这件事。
Earl said, I was in jail last night. I said, why? He said, for trespassing.
厄尔说，我昨晚在监狱里。我说，为什么？他说，因为非法入侵。
Trespassing at the store-- Earl says he was charged with trespassing where he works.
在店里非法入侵——厄尔说他被指控在他工作的地方非法入侵。
I was upset. I was burning myself inside. I was, like, this is impossible.
我很难过。我内心像是在燃烧。我心想，这不可能。
Alex is more than just a boss to Earl, more like a father figure to him. Earl has some mental health issues, and in general, he has a kid-like quality. He first started coming to the Quickstop years before, when he was 14. He had just moved around the corner, but his family life was rough. And his mom couldn't really take care of him. So Alex started keeping an eye on him. Here's Earl.
亚历克斯对厄尔来说不仅仅是老板，更像是父亲的角色。厄尔有一些心理健康问题，总体上有一种孩子气。他是在多年前，也就是14岁时第一次开始到“快停”店来的。他刚搬到拐角处，但家庭生活很艰难。他妈妈无法真正照顾他。所以亚历克斯开始照看他。听听厄尔怎么说。
That's why I started hanging around the store, you know, it's because Alex treat me like a son, though. Sometimes he let me credit stuff, like milk or something, bread or something. I'd go to the store and get it. I'd holler at him. And then he gave me a job, and I started working. I love my job. I love working at it. We're like a family, though.
这就是我开始在店里闲逛的原因，你知道，因为亚历克斯真的像对待儿子一样对待我。有时他让我赊账，买些牛奶、面包之类的东西。我到店里去拿。我会喊他。然后他给了我一份工作，我就开始干活了。我热爱我的工作。我喜欢在那里工作。我们就像一家人一样。
That incident with the police, where Alex walked outside to check on Earl at the end of the night and found only a dustpan and broom, that happened two more times that month.
那次和警察的冲突——亚历克斯晚上出去检查厄尔，只发现簸箕和扫帚——那个月又发生了两次。
They'll like, come and grab me from, like, outside. Like, they won't go in the store and ask Alex or nothing, though. They would just grab me, put me in a police car, take me down to jail, you know? I'm like, well, I work here, though. You feel me?
他们会像，过来把我从外面抓走。就像，他们不会进店去问亚历克斯或什么的。他们就是抓我，把我放进警车，带我去监狱，你知道吗？我说，好吧，但我在这里工作啊。你懂我意思吗？
So you would say, I work here. And what would they say?
所以你会说，我在这里工作。他们会说什么？
Come on. You ain't supposed to be here. You trespassing here. I'd be like, ask my boss. I would be telling, ask my boss. They're still, oh, we don't care. They'll take me down.
少来了。你不该出现在这里。你在这里非法入侵。我会说，去问我老板。我会一直说，去问我老板。他们还是说，哦，我们不在乎。他们就把我带走了。
Each time the police picked up Earl, they'd book him into the county jail. He'd spend the night there, go to court the next day, and there he'd be given a choice. Plead guilty to trespassing and get out of jail right away, or he could fight the trespassing charge, but it would be a hassle. And it would be expensive. He'd have to hire a lawyer and post bond and wait for a trial date. So Earl always pleaded guilty.
每次警察带走厄尔，他们都会把他关进县监狱。他会在那里过夜，第二天上法庭，在那里他会被给出一个选择。承认非法入侵罪并立即出狱，或者他可以抗辩非法入侵指控，但这会很麻烦。而且会很昂贵。他得雇律师、交保释金并等待审判日期。所以厄尔总是认罪。
Some of the officers coming into Alex's store were from a specialized unit that was one of the pillars of the new police department. Their job was to fight serious crime in the city. So Alex wanted to know, why were they even bothering with his store? Why were they bothering with Earl? He says he went and talked to their boss, the commander of investigations, Major Anthony Chapman.
进入亚历克斯店里的一些警察来自一个专门小组，那是新警察部门的支柱之一。他们的工作是打击城市中的严重犯罪。所以亚历克斯想知道，为什么他们要打扰他的店？为什么要找厄尔的麻烦？他说他去找了他们的上司，调查指挥官安东尼·查普曼（Anthony Chapman）少校谈话。
I explained to Major Chapman the situation was going on in the store with the different specialized unit that was coming and threatening my guy, my clerks, threatening my customers. You know, he told me, don't worry about it. Everything is going to be fine. I'm trained to handle this. I'm going to talk to my guys. And he told me, this is my phone number. You can call me anytime. Obviously, it was a big mistake.
我向查普曼少校解释了店里发生的情况，不同的专门小组过来威胁我的员工、我的店员、威胁我的顾客。你知道，他告诉我，别担心。一切都会好起来的。我受过训练来处理这件事。我会和我的手下谈谈。他还给了我他的电话号码。他说你可以随时打电话给我。显然，这是一个大错误。
A mistake because officers started showing up more and more, he says.
一个错误，因为他说警察开始出现得越来越多。
Actually, one day one of the officers from the specialized unit, a female, drove to the parking lot, put the window down and said, great complaint. She stick the finger on me, the middle finger, like [BLEEP] you. And at that time, I was kind of scared. I don't know what to do. It was, like, you feel like you can't do anything about it.
其实，有一天，专门小组的一名女警官开车到停车场，摇下车窗说，很棒的投诉。她对我竖起手指，中指，就像“去你的”。那时，我有点害怕。我不知道该怎么办。就像，你觉得你对此无能为力。
Alex had never felt this way about the police, that they were not on his side. He thought maybe he could make them go away by quitting the zero tolerance program. So he took down the sign from his store. When he showed up one morning, someone had screwed another one back into its place.
亚历克斯从来没有这样看待过警察，认为他们不是站在自己这边的。他想也许他可以通过退出零容忍计划让他们离开。所以他从店里取下了那个标志。当他一天早上到店里时，有人把另一个标志又拧回原位了。
Meanwhile, Earl was now getting picked up everywhere, all over town. Three years into the program, he had been arrested 63 times and stopped another 99 times. On the police reports, the reason was almost always the same. Earl seemed, quote, "suspicious." Suspicious while waiting at the bus stop or playing basketball for buying food or walking to a public restroom-- only once did Earl run.
与此同时，厄尔现在在城里到处被带走。计划实施三年后，他被捕了63次，被拦下盘问了99次。在警方的报告中，原因几乎总是相同的。厄尔看起来，引用“可疑”。在公共汽车站等车、打篮球、买食物或去公共厕所时表现可疑——厄尔只有一次逃跑。
In the arrest report, the officer wrote, quote, "Earl stated that he was running because he was tired of the police arresting him for no reason." After that, Earl says it was just easier to give himself up.
在逮捕报告中，警官写道，引用“厄尔说他逃跑是因为他厌倦了警察无缘无故地逮捕他。”那之后，厄尔说干脆束手就擒更容易些。
Sometimes, when they'd pull up, I'd just walk to them and pull out my ID, put my ID on the car, put my hands on the car, because I already know what they're going to do. Put my hands behind my back. I accept what they got for me, though.
有时，当他们开车过来时，我就直接走过去拿出身份证，把证件放在车上，把手放在车上，因为我已经知道他们会做什么了。把手放到背后。不过，我接受他们对我所做的一切。
Why?
为什么？
Because I'd be too scared. I'd be scared they're going to shoot me. Man, it was like I was a target, though. Like, everywhere they see me, they'll stop me. I was getting trespassing from the park, the library. Sometimes they used to come around my door at 5 o'clock in the morning looking, like I'm really like a fugitive or something.
因为我太害怕了。我怕他们会开枪打死我。伙计，就像我是一个目标一样。就像，他们无论在哪里见到我，都会拦下我。我在公园、图书馆被当作非法入侵者对待。有时他们甚至在凌晨5点过来敲我的门，就好像我是个逃犯之类的。
Why were they after him?
他们为什么要针对他？
Every time he got arrested, he never fought back. He'd just follow whatever they tell him to do. Earl, honestly, is a quiet kid.
每次他被捕，他从不反抗。他只是照着他们说的做。厄尔，老实说，是个安静的孩子。
In other words, easy pickings for the police. That's the only explanation Alex could think of. It's not like Earl had some serious criminal record. He was so shy that Alex gave him jobs like cleaning and stocking so he didn't have to interact with customers much. It almost seemed like officers were saying to each, other flat out--
换句话说，对警察来说很容易得手。这是亚历克斯唯一能想到的解释。厄尔又不是有什么严重的犯罪记录。他太害羞了，亚历克斯让他干清洁和理货的工作，这样他就不必和顾客有太多交流。这看起来几乎就像警察在相互直白地暗示——
Let's go over to the Quickstop. We'll stop Earl-- low-hanging fruit.
我们去“快停”吧。我们拦下厄尔——软柿子。
This is Jeff Mason. He was a sergeant with the Miami Gardens police. Alex knew him. His store was in his district, and Alex flagged him down a couple times to complain about what was happening at his store.
这是杰夫·梅森（Jeff Mason）。他曾是迈阿密花园警察局的一名警长。亚历克斯认识他。他的店就在他的辖区内，亚历克斯曾几次拦下他投诉店里发生的事情。
Jeff told him it was no accident that some officers were targeting Earl. Orders had been coming down. They needed to bring in numbers.
杰夫告诉他，有些警察针对厄尔并非偶然。命令已经传达下来了。他们需要完成指标。
We would have roll calls, not only with the sergeants but with the captains. And, yeah, the message would be we need to see evidence that you guys are making an impact. And you need to justify your existence through numbers. You stop enough people, you'll find something.
我们会进行点名，不仅是与警长，还有队长。是的，传达的信息是我们希望看到你们这些人正在产生影响的证据。你们需要通过数字来证明你们存在的合理性。拦下足够多的人，你们总会发现点什么的。
These were new officers in a new police department that was trying to prove itself. Their zero tolerance program was a version of the broken windows policing theory that seemed so successful in other cities. If you stamp out small offenses, the theory goes, it deters bigger ones. They were sending a message to residents in Miami Gardens that no crime would go unchecked. So officers had to prove they were catching the small stuff, Jeff says, like trespassing.
这些是一个试图证明自己的新警察部门里的新警员。他们的零容忍计划是“破窗理论”治安的一种版本，该理论在其他城市似乎非常成功。理论认为，如果你铲除小罪行，就能威慑更大的罪行。他们正在向迈阿密花园的居民传达一个信息，即任何犯罪都逃不过法网。所以警察必须证明他们在抓小事，杰夫说，比如非法入侵。
As supervisors, we were expected to do our monthly stats sheet, to tally up pretty much everything that the officers did on a daily basis, turn it in. And at one time it was posted. You know, you had competition between platoons and squads. So the culture was established to where if you wanted to get anywhere in that department or if you wanted to get promoted, then you would bring in numbers.
作为主管，我们被要求制作每月的统计表，记录警察每天所做的几乎每一件事，并上交。曾经还有过一次张贴出来。你知道，排和班之间存在竞争。因此，一种文化就形成了：如果你想在那个部门有任何进展，或者如果你想获得晋升，那么你就会带回数字。
It seemed like this was what residents wanted. Minutes from city council meetings for those first few years show hardly any complaints about police harassment. If anything, when people did complain, it was because they felt like officers weren't responding fast enough. They wanted more police.
看起来这正是居民们想要的。前几年的市议会会议记录显示，几乎没有关于警察骚扰的投诉。如果有投诉，那是因为他们觉得警察反应不够快。他们想要更多的警察。
By 2012, four years into the zero tolerance program, the violent crimes that people were most concerned about had not dropped. In fact, murders had increased, and so had assaults. Though burglaries were down, and vehicle thefts fell by half.
到2012年，零容忍计划实施四年后，人们最担心的暴力犯罪并没有下降。事实上，谋杀案增加了，袭击案也是如此。虽然入室盗窃有所减少，车辆盗窃案减少了一半。
Meanwhile, after four years of Earl getting stopped constantly, everywhere he went, Earl and Alex had tried all the normal things you do when you're having problems with the police. So Alex came up with a plan-- a pretty extreme one.
与此同时，在厄尔不断被拦截盘问四年之后，厄尔和亚历克斯尝试了所有当你遇到警察问题时会做的正常事情。所以亚历克斯想出了一个计划——一个相当极端的计划。
I explained to Earl. I said, Earl, I think the better place for you to live is inside the store. You know, we bring mattress, stuff like that, and I told him, you live here. You sleep here. Anything you need to eat and drink at night when you're here, you can, you know, you can get it.
我向厄尔解释。我说，厄尔，我觉得你住的地方最好的就是店里。你知道，我们带上床垫之类东西，我告诉他，你就住在这儿。你睡在这儿。晚上你需要吃的喝的，你可以拿。
Way in the back corner of the store, at the end of an aisle, there's an 11 by 11 foot room built out of plywood and sheet rock. And inside that room is a mattress and a sink for Earl to wash up in. If you were picking up laundry detergent or toilet paper, you'd be standing right next to where he sleeps.
在店的最里角，过道的尽头，有一个11乘11英尺的房间，是用胶合板和石膏板建成的。房间里有一个床垫和一个供厄尔洗漱的水槽。如果你去拿洗衣液或卫生纸，你会直接站在他睡觉的地方旁边。
But even that didn't prevent the police from coming in and getting Earl. Not long after his room was built, he got arrested again for trespassing at the store. Earl didn't immediately take a plea this time. Alex doesn't know why, but Earl spent 20 days in jail. And the judge issued a stay away warning from the store.
但即使这样也没能阻止警察进来带走厄尔。他的房间建好后不久，他又因为在店里非法入侵而被捕。厄尔这次没有立即认罪。亚历克斯不知道为什么，但厄尔在监狱里呆了20天。法官下达了远离商店的警告。
Alex's next move-- he bought a surveillance camera. In fact, he bought four. He decided that that was the only way anyone would believe that he wasn't making this stuff up.
亚历克斯的下一步——他买了一个监控摄像头。事实上，他买了四个。他认为这是让任何人相信他没有捏造这些东西的唯一途径。
It's like, I don't know how to fight back. But I said, you know what, I have it on video. Let them keep doing it on video.
就像，我不知道怎么反抗。但我说，你知道吗，我有视频。让他们继续做，我有视频记录。
Soon he was up to 16 cameras, covering his store inside and out.
很快他就有16个摄像头了，覆盖了店里店外。
Now, on camera five, you're going to see Officer William Dunaske taking Earl out of the store.
现在，在五号摄像头上，你将看到警官威廉·杜纳斯克（William Dunaske）把厄尔从店里带走。
Alex showed me some of the videos. There's no sound on them. His cameras don't have microphones, but it's incredible to watch police just come in and grab Earl while he's stocking coolers or taking out the trash. In one video, two police officers are walking up and down the aisles, glancing at customers. And then they head straight for Earl's room in the back of the store. And they take their guns out.
亚历克斯给我看了些视频。它们没有声音。他的摄像头没有麦克风，但看警察走进店里，趁厄尔在给冰柜理货或倒垃圾时直接抓住他，真是令人难以置信。在一段视频中，两名警察在过道里走来走去，扫视顾客。然后他们径直走向店后的厄尔的房间。他们拔出了枪。
I'm laying in my room, and the door just opened. And I see the police. I'm like, dang. I'm like, what I done did? They like, oh, you ain't supposed to be here. Get out of the room.
我躺在房间里，门突然开了。我看到了警察。我心想，该死。我心想，我干了什么？他们说，哦，你不该在这儿。滚出这个房间。
So, what, you're putting your shoes on in the aisle?
所以，怎么，你在过道里穿鞋？
Mm-hm. In the aisle, though. I'm putting on my shoes in the aisle, though.
嗯。在过道里。我正在过道里穿鞋。
In the videos, the cops pretty much leave Alex's other employees alone. His other employees aren't black. His customers are. And one of the overwhelming things about watching these videos is the pleasure some officers seem to take in harassing them.
在视频中，警察几乎不打扰亚历克斯的其他员工。他的其他员工不是黑人。而他的顾客是。观看这些视频最震撼人心的一点是，一些警察似乎以骚扰他们为乐。
In one video, a woman in a skirt sits on top of a newspaper box outside the store. A police officer grabs her purse and starts rummaging through it. He turns it upside down and dumps the contents onto the ground. And then he just kicks her stuff around. The officer in this instance is Michael Malone. Of all the police officers Alex captured on tape, he stands out as the biggest bully. In another scene, Malone takes a guy's bag of Red Bulls and hurls the cans all over the sidewalk.
在一段视频中，一个穿着裙子的女人坐在店外的一个报纸箱上。一名警察抢走了她的钱包，开始在里面翻找。他把它倒过来，把里面的东西倒在地上。然后他直接踢开她的东西。在这种情况下，该警官是迈克尔·马龙（Michael Malone）。在亚历克斯拍到的所有警察中，他表现得最像个恶霸。在另一个场景中，马龙拿走了一个人的红牛饮料袋，把罐子扔得满人行道都是。
And I went to the officer and said, you know what, why you throw all those Red Bull all over the place, man? You think that was right? He said, fuck him. Why do you care?
我走向那个警察说，你知道吗，你为什么把那些红牛扔得满地都是，伙计？你觉得那样做对吗？他说，去他的。你管什么？
Alex continued complaining to the police department and continued to get nowhere. And then, he says, one day, not long after one of these complaints, a group of officers showed up at the store with their Sergeant-- Sergeant Martin Santiago.
亚历克斯继续向警察部门投诉，并继续毫无进展。然后，他说，一天，在这些投诉后不久，一群警察带着他们的警长——马丁·圣地亚哥（Martin Santiago）警长出现在店里。
They stood in a line, shoulder to shoulder, blocking the aisles. Another time, Alex says, they confronted him outside the store. He started to feel like they weren't just going after Earl anymore. They were going after him, too.
他们肩并肩排成一排，堵住了过道。还有一次，亚历克斯说，他们在店外与他对抗。他开始觉得他们不只是冲着厄尔去了。他们也是冲着他去了。
Officers followed me from the store, four blocks away. And they stopped me. And that traffic stop was six police cars. And that's when Sergeant Santiago walked to my window. He said my tailgate light was out. Tires-- he said, your tire is bald. So I'm like, OK. My tire's not bald.
警察跟着我离开商店，跟着走了四个街区。然后他们拦下了我。那次交通拦截来了六辆警车。那时圣地亚哥警长走到我的车窗前。他说我的尾灯坏了。轮胎——他说，你的轮胎磨平了。所以我说，好的。我的轮胎没磨平。
And so what happened after that?
那之后发生了什么？
The sergeant, Santiago, came to the passenger side and told me, I'm gonna get you, motherfucker. I was kind of getting scared. And I was home. I was thinking, you know, the only way that those officers and the department feel pressure is to show the whole world what's going on-- just to have it on record to protect myself.
那个圣地亚哥警长走到副驾驶那边说，我要整死你，混蛋。我当时有点害怕。我在家里时想，你知道，让那些警察和部门感受到压力的唯一方法，就是向全世界展示正在发生的事情——只是为了有记录在案，以保护我自己。
So he walked into a building he'd never been in before, the offices of the Miami Herald, and asked to speak to a reporter. Two months later, the Herald published Alex's story on the front page and put some of the surveillance videos online. One of the Herald's reporters, Julie Brown, pulled records that showed police had arrested Earl at least 62 times for trespassing.
所以他走进了一栋他从未进去过的大楼——《迈阿密先驱报》的办公室，要求采访一位记者。两个月后，《先驱报》在头版发表了亚历克斯的故事，并将部分监控视频发布在网上。该报的一名记者朱莉·布朗（Julie Brown）调阅的记录显示，警方至少以非法入侵罪逮捕了厄尔62次。
Most of the citations were issued at the Quickstop. And overall, Earl had been stopped and questioned more than 250 times. His criminal record was 38 pages long.
大多数传票都是在“快停”店开出的。总的来说，厄尔被拦下盘问了超过250次。他的犯罪记录长达38页。
News outlets all over the country picked up the story.
全国各地的新闻媒体都报道了这个故事。
Right now at 5:30, Miami Gardens police are being questioned about officers stopping and harassing customers at a particular convenience store.
现在是5点30分，迈阿密花园警察因在某家便利店拦截和骚扰顾客而受到质疑。
My biggest surprise that we have at least about 30, 40 reporters in the parking lot, of every TV station, every radio station, newspaper. I got people drove from Tampa-- a family. The whole family just came. They want to shake my hand. I feel happy. That day was, honestly, was like a party, actually, yes.
我最大的惊喜是停车场里至少有30、40名记者，来自每个电视台、广播电台、报纸。甚至有从坦帕开车过来的一家人。全家人都来了。他们想握我的手。我感到很高兴。那天，老实说，简直就像一场聚会。
The press attention worked. Police now completely avoided the Quickstop. To Alex, it was a huge relief. But the story of police harassment was about to go way beyond just Earl. Two investigative journalists, Alice Brennan and Dan Lieberman, they're from a new startup called Fusion. And they decided to compile stats for all the stops the Miami Gardens Police Department had made since it first started in 2008.
媒体的关注起作用了。警察现在完全避开了“快停”店。对亚历克斯来说，这是一个巨大的解脱。但警察骚扰的故事即将远远超出厄尔的范围。两位调查记者爱丽丝·布伦南（Alice Brennan）和丹·利伯曼（Dan Lieberman）来自一家名为Fusion的新创业公司。他们决定统计迈阿密花园警察局自2008年成立以来进行的所有拦检记录。
It was stunning.
结果令人震惊。
This is Alice.
这是爱丽丝。
The results were stunning. Because in a city of 110,000 people-- Miami Gardens only has 110,000 people. And the number of stops that had occurred over a five-year period was 99,980. And so then to compare that to the city of Miami-- it has a population four times as large as Miami Gardens-- over the same period of time, they had only made 3,753 stops.
结果令人震惊。因为在一个11万人口的城市——迈阿密花园只有11万人。在五年时间里，拦检次数竟然达到了99,980次。那么与迈阿密市相比——它的人口是迈阿密花园的四倍——在同一时期，他们只进行了3,753次拦检。
3,700 stops for the city of Miami, compared to 99,000 for Miami Gardens.
迈阿密市只有3,700次拦检，而迈阿密花园有99,000次。
It's like, I'm going to have to look at that again because what?
就好像，我得再看一遍这个数字，因为什么？
When you first saw that, did you think that number was wrong?
当你第一次看到那个数字时，你以为它错了吗？
I did. I'm like, this can't be real. This can't be real. This cannot be happening. I thought all of the data was wrong.
我是这样想的。我心想，这不可能。这不可能。这不可能发生。我以为所有的数据都错了。
It wasn't wrong. What shocked Alice the most, though, was more than 11,000 of the stops were for kids. Kids who, in the field contact reports, were labeled suspicious while doing things like playing freeze tag, riding bikes, swimming at pools, or hanging out a public park. To give me a better sense of just how strange all these police stops looked, Alice ran me through her spreadsheet.
并没有错。不过，让爱丽丝最震惊的是，11,000多次拦检对象是孩子。在现场接触记录中，这些孩子在做诸如玩木头人游戏、骑自行车、在泳池游泳或在公园闲逛时，都被贴上了“可疑”的标签。为了让我更清楚地了解所有这些警察拦检看起来有多奇怪，爱丽丝带我看了她的电子表格。
I'll just sort this really quickly for you. Here we go. So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to sort for age, right? So we've got ages one, two, we've got seven year olds.
我为你快速排序一下。这就是了。我现在要做的是按年龄排序，对吧？所以有1岁、2岁的，甚至有7岁的孩子。
This is a particularly alarming one. Five years old this kid is, and it says, the listed subject was fitting the description of the suspect in the area of a burglary.
这是一个特别令人震惊的例子。这个孩子才5岁，记录上说，所列主体符合该地区入室盗窃嫌疑人的描述。
I mean, what is that?
我的意思是，那是什么？
Who knows? OK, so here's another one. This kid was seven years old, stopped for being a suspicious person. Officer says in the remarks, "I was dispatched to the above location. Several subjects, possibly selling narcotics. This subject was observed in front of this location. And pat searched was conducted after consent. No wants nor warrants."
谁知道呢？好了，再看这个。这个孩子7岁，因为是“可疑人物”被拦下。警察在备注中写道：“我被派往上述地点。几名主体，可能在兜售毒品。该主体在该地点前面被发现。经同意进行了搜身。没有通缉记录，没有搜捕令。”
So they say they ran a seven-year-old's name.
所以他们说他们查了一个7岁孩子的名字。
Yeah, they ran the name. And what do you know? No wants or warrants were found. It says here in the physical characteristics that this seven-year-old had a slight beard.
是的，他们查了名字。结果呢？没有发现通缉记录或搜捕令。这里写着体貌特征，说这个7岁孩子有“轻微胡须”。
Right now, Miami Gardens has at least five lawsuits filed against it, all alleging that the police engaged in serious misconduct, racial profiling, and were operating according to a quota system. One of those is a civil rights lawsuit brought by Alex. Two other cases were brought by whistleblowers, former police employees who say that when they spoke out against the department's pressure to rack up numbers, their positions were terminated.
现在，迈阿密花园至少有五起针对它的诉讼，全都指控警方存在严重的不当行为、种族定性，并按配额制行事。其中一起是亚历克斯提起的民权诉讼。另外两起案件是由举报人提起的，他们是前警察局员工，声称当他们公开反对部门按数字行事的压力时，他们的职位被终止了。
Miami Gardens officials, through their lawyers, denied all of these allegations and didn't respond to multiple requests for interviews about the cases and about Alice's numbers. Wanda Gilbert is one of the whistle blowers suing Miami Gardens. She was a crime analyst at Miami Garden's PD from 2007 to 2011. It was her job to compile all the field contact numbers and present them at regular staff meetings.
迈阿密花园的官员通过他们的律师否认了所有这些指控，并且没有回应多次关于这些案件和爱丽丝统计数字的采访请求。万达·吉尔伯特（Wanda Gilbert）是起诉迈阿密花园的举报人之一。她曾在2007年至2011年担任迈阿密花园警局的犯罪分析师。她的工作是汇编所有现场接触记录数字，并在定期员工会议上展示。
What she realized looking at all those numbers, Wanda says, was that they had no meaningful connection to fighting real crime or making the city safer. No one was saying--
万达说，看着所有这些数字，她意识到它们与打击真正的犯罪或让城市更安全没有任何有意义的联系。从来没有人说过——
OK, we did 556 field contacts. So therefore, by them doing this, we only had one burglary-- never. It was just gathering stats.
好了，我们进行了556次现场接触。因此，因为他们这样做，我们只发生了一起入室盗窃——从来没有。这只是为了收集统计数据。
In her old job, Wanda says, officers would look at their field contacts database for suspects when they were trying to solve a crime. But Miami Gardens had collected so many people in its database that it wasn't helpful at all. Jeff Mason filed the other whistleblower lawsuit against the city.
万达说，在她以前的工作中，警察在试图破案时会查看他们的现场接触数据库以寻找嫌疑人。但迈阿密花园在数据库中收集了太多人，以至于根本没用。杰夫·梅森提起了针对该市的另一起举报人诉讼。
He's the former patrol sergeant you heard earlier. They were making so many stops, Jeff says, that supervisors like him couldn't keep up. That five-year-old who was written up as a burglary suspect? Jeff signed off on that one.
他就是你之前听到的那位前巡逻警长。杰夫说，他们进行的拦检次数太多了，像他这样的主管跟不上。那个被记录为入室盗窃嫌疑人的5岁孩子？杰夫在那份报告上签了字。
I mean, how many supervisors do you think were actually reading the remarks on these?
我的意思是，你认为有多少主管真的在读这些备注？
Um, as a supervisor, because there were so many coming through, to be specifically reading the remarks, it was next to impossible.
嗯，作为主管，因为经过的人太多，要专门去读备注，几乎是不可能的。
If the numbers weren't being used in the service of smart policing, than what purpose did they serve? When I first started reporting this story, I heard speculation that the Miami Gardens Police Department needed these numbers in order to get federal grants.
如果数字不是用于“智能警务”服务，那么它们有什么用？当我开始报道这个故事时，我听到有人推测迈阿密花园警察局需要这些数字是为了获得联邦拨款。
There have been reports about other police departments been fixated on quotas and numbers for this purpose. Miami Gardens police received 21 grants, with millions of dollars from the Department of Justice Community Policing Program. But I read through a lot of those applications. Field contact numbers were not a requirement to qualify. They rarely came up at all.
有报道称其他警察部门为了这个目的而纠结于配额和数字。迈阿密花园警察获得了21笔拨款，从司法部社区警务计划中获得了数百万美元。但我阅读了大量申请材料。现场接触数字并不是获得资格的要求。它们很少出现。
I also looked through city council minutes. I thought maybe the police chief was presenting field contact numbers to the city to show that his department was making an impact. But no, nothing there either. In five years, the chief mentioned field contacts only once. So where did this policy come from? Well, I started with the person who was running the city at the time-- Mayor Shirley Gibson. She says she didn't know anything about it or the 99,000 stops that happened in the city.
我还查阅了市议会会议纪要。我以为也许警察局长向该市展示了现场接触数字，以证明他的部门正在产生影响。但不，那里也没有。在五年里，局长只提到过一次现场接触。那么这个政策是从哪里来的呢？嗯，我从当时掌管该市的人——市长雪莉·吉布森（Shirley Gibson）开始调查。她说她对这件事一无所知，对发生在城市里的99,000次拦检也一无所知。
I'm not saying, you know, it's true or untrue. I just don't know, so I'm not going to have a comment. OK, they did this, or they didn't do that. I'm just telling you I had no knowledge of that. And I'm not trying to not say I have some responsibility, but I didn't know about it.
我不是说，你知道，这是真的还是假的。我只是不知道，所以我不会发表评论。好吧，他们做了这个，或者没做那个。我只是告诉你我对此一无所知。我并不是试图逃避责任，但我确实不知道。
So many people have denied responsibility for these numbers. No one will say, this policy started with me. No one could point to a piece of paper or a meeting where it was adopted. No one could say where it came from or why.
这么多人否认对这些数字负责。没人说，这项政策是从我这里开始的。没人能指出一份文件或一次采用该政策的会议。没人能说出它来自哪里，为什么会出现。
And as much as it may be satisfying to find one culprit who's responsible for a department run amok, or one idea that spread and infected so many of its officers, the reality is it failed in the way that so many systems fail-- a whole bunch of mistakes that compounded over time. No one had a clear vision for what they were doing and why. And in the absence of a plan, things went bad in big ways and small ways.
虽然找到一个对部门失控负责的罪魁祸首，或者找到一个传播并感染了如此多警官的某种想法，可能会让人感到满足，但现实是，它的失败方式与如此多系统的失败方式一样——一系列随着时间推移而复合的错误。没有人清楚自己在做什么，为什么要这样做。在缺乏计划的情况下，事情在大大小小方面都变糟了。
One thing that's clear is there was a weird lack of accountability in Miami Gardens. Officially, the police were supposed to be overseen by an entity called the City Manager's Office, which many people told me was asleep on the job. There was a city council that appears to have been totally in the dark. The mayor, like you heard, says she had no idea. And there was a police chief, Matthew Boyd, who didn't really seem like he was around much.
有一点很清楚，迈阿密花园在问责方面存在一种奇怪的缺失。官方上，警察应该由一个叫市经理办公室的实体监管，许多人告诉我那是形同虚设的。市议会似乎完全被蒙在鼓里。市长，正如你听到的，说她一无所知。还有一位警察局长马修·博伊德（Matthew Boyd），他似乎并不怎么在位。
He was a great guy in the beginning. He was everywhere. He was out there in his car, running around, you know, doing stuff.
起初他是个很棒的人。他到处都是。他开着车跑来跑去，你知道，做各种事情。
This is Stephen Kolackovsky He was a sergeant in Miami Gardens from 2007 to 2010.
这是斯蒂芬·科拉科夫斯基（Stephen Kolackovsky）。他曾在2007年至2010年在迈阿密花园担任警长。
By year three, I never saw him, and then, you know, the rumor starts that that city controller busted him in the butt about golfing too much and stuff. I don't know.
到第三年，我就再没见过他，然后，你知道，传言就开始了，说城市审计员因为他打高尔夫太多而训斥了他。我不知道。
A former vice mayor from Miami Gardens told me he doesn't know if the city ever officially reprimanded Boyd for playing too much golf. But he does remember that it was a problem. Boyd's golf game also came up with every former police employee I talked to. Boyd has denied misusing company time. As Stephen remembers it, there just seemed to be an absence at the top that was confusing.
一位迈阿密花园的前副市长告诉我，他不知道该市是否正式谴责过博伊德打高尔夫太多。但他确实记得那是个问题。博伊德的高尔夫球瘾也出现在我和每一位前警局员工的交谈中。博伊德否认滥用工作时间。斯蒂芬记得，顶层的缺位让人感到困惑。
Maybe he started the department, got it going, felt he was done. And maybe he just didn't want to be there anymore. I'd like to ask him that, though. I'd like to know why. It almost felt like it was a ship without a captain, and that's kind of the way everybody-- well, I felt and a lot of the people I knew felt, like, you know, there's no chief here. You know what I mean? Like, everybody knew he wasn't around, and they had the first mate running the boat.
也许他建立了这个部门，让它运转起来，觉得他已经完成了。也许他只是不想再待在那里了。不过我很想问问他。我很想知道原因。它感觉几乎就像一艘没有船长的船，每个人都这么觉得——好吧，我感觉，我认识的很多人也都感觉，就好像，你知道，这里没有局长。你明白我的意思吗？就像，每个人都知道他不在位，他们让大副在管理这艘船。
The first mate, in this case, was the former deputy chief. Like the chief, he's denied being the person who brought this policy to Miami Gardens. Their attorney declined my request for interviews.
在这种情况下，大副是前副局长。像局长一样，他也否认自己是给迈阿密花园带来这项政策的人。他们的律师拒绝了我的采访请求。
While no one will take responsibility for initiating the policy, former department employees say the message that officers needed to stop and question large numbers of residents was being conveyed loud and clear. And the officers on the receiving end of that message were mostly white and Hispanic and they weren't from Miami Gardens or anywhere nearby. And generally speaking, they had little experience dealing with a black population. Wanda Gilbert, the former crime analyst, did some of the background checks during hiring.
虽然没人愿意承担发起这项政策的责任，但该部门的前员工表示，警察需要拦截并盘问大量居民的信息传达得非常清楚和响亮。而接收到该信息的警察大多是白人和西班牙裔，他们并不来自迈阿密花园或附近任何地方。总的来说，他们在处理黑人人口方面经验很少。万达·吉尔伯特，这位前犯罪分析师，在招聘期间做了一些背景调查。
And one of the things that I had even spoke to the chief about, because I'm doing the background work on these people, I'm going, like, what's going on here? What's going on here because, you know, it was a vast amount of white officers.
我甚至和局长谈过的一件事是，因为我在做这些人的背景工作，我心想，这里发生了什么？因为，你知道，有大量的白人警察。
And second, what was the demographic then, mostly, of the officers, if you were to break it down?
其次，如果划分的话，当时的警察人口构成主要是怎样的？
If I break it down, I think at the time the department was like 200 and maybe 26. And out of that, it was probably maybe 40-- and that's guesstimating high-- but that includes all the black officers. And one of the things that was a challenge to us, because a lot of the officers were new-- meaning they were from various areas around the United States.
如果我划分一下，我想当时部门大约有226人。其中，可能也就40人——这还是高估的——但这包括了所有的黑人警察。我们要面临的一个挑战是，很多警察是新来的——意味着他们来自美国各地。
Like where?
比如哪里？
Oh, from Alaska, Kansas, Missouri-- you name it. They were from around the country. And some of them, this was all new to them-- not only just being Miami Gardens, but also, too, here they are, some of them, now they're working with a black community. And that was a problem. You didn't know the nuances. In fact, I've even heard officers say that, oh, everybody in this community is, you know, is a criminal.
噢，从阿拉斯加、堪萨斯、密苏里——你说得出来的都有。他们来自全国各地。对其中一些人来说，这一切都是新的——不仅是来到迈阿密花园，而且，这里还有，有些人，现在他们要与黑人社区合作。那是个问题。你不知道其中的微妙之处。事实上，我甚至听到警察说，哦，这个社区里的每个人，你知道，都是罪犯。
Former city council members and police employees who were involved in hiring all say that they did try hard to recruit from local police departments, but many in the area thought that the newly formed Miami Gardens Police wouldn't last longer than a year. And so local officers didn't want to risk taking jobs there. Stephen Kolackovsky, he was a sergeant in Miami gardens from 2007 to 2010.
参与招聘的前市议会议员和警局员工都表示，他们确实努力从当地警察部门招人，但该地区的许多人认为新成立的迈阿密花园警察局持续不了多久。所以当地警察不想冒险去那里工作。斯蒂芬·科拉科夫斯基在2007年至2010年担任迈阿密花园警长。
He came down from the Baltimore Police Department, and he says that in Miami Gardens, they ended up with a lot of officers who just seemed out of place.
他从巴尔的摩警察局调过来，他说在迈阿密花园，他们最终得到了一堆看起来格格不入的警察。
You know, you could see it on their face. They were in culture shock. Like, it was almost overwhelming to them. Just, you could almost see they were nervous. And sometimes I wondered to myself, you know, what are you doing here? You know, just what are you doing here? Go back home.
你知道，你可以从他们的脸上看出来。他们受到了文化冲击。就像，这对他们来说几乎是无法承受的。你可以看出他们很紧张。有时我自己会纳闷，你知道，你在这里做什么？你知道，你到底在这里做什么？回老家去吧。
Because Alex spoke up, some serious changes have taken place in Miami Gardens. The police chief, Matthew Boyd, and his deputy-- they're both gone now. The new police chief is a guy named Stephen Johnson, and he reports every week to a new city manager.
因为亚历克斯说了出来，迈阿密花园发生了一些重大改变。警察局长马修·博伊德和他的副手——他们现在都走了。新的警察局长叫斯蒂芬·约翰逊（Stephen Johnson），他每周向一位新的市经理报告。
Johnson keeps him in the loop about how many times police are stopping residents. In the last year, those numbers have dropped about 70%. Alex has talked to the new police chief, and he likes him. He likes that Johnson gives out his personal cell phone number to residents. But Alex is still on edge.
约翰逊让他了解警察拦检居民的频率。在过去的一年里，这些数字下降了约70%。亚历克斯和新警察局长谈过，他喜欢他。他喜欢约翰逊把他个人的手机号码给居民。但亚历克斯仍然感到紧张。
I really still don't feel comfortable. I don't. Honestly, I don't feel comfortable right now if they're going to come or if they're not going to come back. Because there's still some of the officers in the city.
我真的还是不觉得舒服。不。老实说，如果他们要来或者如果不回来，我现在真的不觉得舒服。因为城里还有一些那样的警察。
The officers that came to your store are still on the force.
去过你店里的警察还在警队。
Yeah, there's still the same officers still in the street.
是的，街上还有同样的那些警察。
Anthony Chapman, the police commander whose officers repeatedly harassed Alex's customers and Earl, he's still at the police department. He denies all allegations against him and declined to be interviewed. Martin Santiago, the sergeant who Alex says threatened him at a traffic stop, he also still works there, as does William Dunaske, the officer who pulled Earl out of the store in that very first surveillance video.
安东尼·查普曼，那个手下多次骚扰亚历克斯顾客和厄尔的警察指挥官，他还在警察局。他否认了所有针对他的指控，并拒绝接受采访。马丁·圣地亚哥，那个亚历克斯说在交通拦截中威胁他的警长，也还在那里工作，威廉·杜纳斯克——那个在第一段监控视频中把厄尔从店里拉出来的警察也一样。
The city declined to make Santiago and Dunaske available for comment. Michael Malone, the officer who threw and kicked customers' personal things, he did leave the force, but it was voluntary. An internal affairs report concedes misconduct, but Malone was never disciplined for his actions. He could not be reached for comment.
该市拒绝提供圣地亚哥和杜纳斯克的评论。迈克尔·马龙——那个扔掉并踢开顾客个人物品的警察，他确实离开了警队，但那是自愿的。一份内部事务报告承认了不当行为，但马龙从未因其行为受到纪律处分。他无法被联系到发表评论。
It's been more than a year and a half since Earl was last stopped, but he doesn't feel safe. His world is still a paranoid one. He still lives at the store and rarely goes out. And when he does, he gets scared.
距离厄尔最后一次被拦截已经过去一年半了，但他并没有感到安全。他的世界仍然是一个偏执的世界。他依然住在店里，很少外出。即使外出时，他也会感到害怕。
Sometimes he goes to the park to play basketball. And if the officer drives by, he calls me.
有时他去公园打篮球。如果有警车开过，他就给我打电话。
I be like, Alex, the police trying to get me. Police-- police coming. I feel like they going to try to harm me, though.
我会说，亚历克斯，警察要来抓我了。警察——警察来了。不过我觉得他们会伤害我。
So I come out of the store, so I can see across the street in the park. But you can see him watching back and forth, like, do you think they're going to stop me, or they're not going to stop me? I said, just walk.
所以我走出店，这样就能看到街对面的公园。但你能看到他在那儿来回观望，就像，你觉得他们会拦我吗，还是不会？我说，走就是了。
Alex will be like, Earl, they ain't going to mess with you no more. I got you, though. I got you, Earl.
亚历克斯会说，厄尔，他们不会再找你麻烦了。我有你，不过。我有你，厄尔。
Right before I said goodbye to Earl, I asked him this one, last question.
就在我和厄尔道别之前，我问了他最后一个问题。
Is there anything I haven't asked you that you want to tell me? Did I miss anything?
有什么我没问你，但你想告诉我的吗？我漏掉了什么吗？
You ain't working for the police, right? You ain't working for the police.
你不是为警察工作的，对吧？你不是为警察工作的。
He asked, are you going to try to do something to me? I told him, no.
他问，你会试图对我做什么吗？我告诉他，不会。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our program.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。
Coming up, wouldn't it be lovely for a change to hear a story about police and black residents that could give any small sense of hope at all? We get to that. We absolutely get to that in the second half of our show. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，如果能听一个关于警察和黑人居民的故事，能带来哪怕一点点希望，难道不是件美妙的事吗？我们会谈到这一点。在节目的下半场，我们绝对会谈到这一点。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- Police See Things Differently, Part Two. It is our second episode with stories about policing and race. We've arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, Comey Don't Play That.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——《警察看待事物的角度，第二部分》。这是我们关于治安和种族故事的第二集。我们已经到了节目的第二幕——第二幕，《科米可不玩那套》。
You may have heard in the news already that FBI director James Comey gave a speech this week that was about the subject of today's program, about policing and race-- a speech that was amazing for its directness and its sweep. He said law enforcement needs to redouble its efforts to resist bias and to do a better job serving black Americans. Attorney General Holder, of course, has said similar things in the past.
你可能已经在新闻中听说过，联邦调查局局长詹姆斯·科米（James Comey）本周发表了一次演讲，主题正是今天节目的主题，关于治安和种族——这次演讲因其直接和全面而令人惊叹。他说执法部门需要加倍努力来抵制偏见，并更好地为美国黑人服务。当然，司法部长霍尔德（Holder）过去也说过类似的话。
Our producer, Robyn Semien-- Robyn is the one who talked to her police officer friend about the Eric Garner video earlier in the show. Robyn has noticed that local heads of police departments in cities around the country do not talk this way in the moment when people are thinking about this the most. And that's after incidents where unarmed black man are killed by white officers.
我们的制作人罗宾·塞米恩——罗宾就是之前在节目中和她的警察朋友谈论埃里克·加纳视频的人。罗宾注意到，当人们最关注这件事的时候，全国各地的警察部门负责人在那个瞬间并不这样说话。那是在手无寸铁的黑人被白人警察杀害的事件发生之后。
Big city police chiefs don't like to talk about race. When they do, they like to say it doesn't matter. New York Police Commissioner, William Bratton, in response to Eric Garner, said, quote, "I personally don't think race was a factor."
大城市警察局长不喜欢谈论种族。当他们谈论时，他们喜欢说这不重要。纽约警察局局长威廉·布拉顿（William Bratton）在回应埃里克·加纳事件时说，引用“我个人认为种族不是一个因素。”
After Oscar Grant was shot in the back, famously, lying face down on a crowded train platform at Fruitvale Station in Oakland, BART Police Chief Gary Gee said there was no, quote, "nexus to race that provoked this to happen." It's what Milwaukee Police Chief Edward Flynn said about race in last week's show.
在奥斯卡·格兰特（Oscar Grant）在奥克兰弗鲁特韦尔车站（Fruitvale Station）拥挤的列车月台上脸朝下躺着被从背后射杀后，湾区快速铁路（BART）警察局长加里·吉（Gary Gee）声称，没有任何（引用）“导致这种情况发生的与种族相关的联系”。这就是密尔沃基警察局长爱德华·弗林（Edward Flynn）在上周的节目中对种族问题的说法。
At the level of cop working in the neighborhood, race is irrelevant.
在社区工作的警察层面，种族是不相关的。
That's what Saratoga Springs Police Department in Utah said, just last week, about 22-year-old Darrien Hunt, also black.
这就是犹他州萨拉托加斯普林斯警察局（Saratoga Springs Police Department）上周对22岁的黑人达里恩·亨特（Darrien Hunt）所说的话。
The attorney for the Saratoga Springs Police Department says race did not play a factor in the shooting death of Darrien Hunt. She says that--
萨拉托加斯普林斯警察局的律师表示，种族在达里恩·亨特被枪杀的案件中没有起到作用。她说——
Every time I hear this, race is not a factor, my gut reaction is the same. Why say that? How would you know? What are you basing that on? Because there's science on this-- in fact, years of research. And that research shows the opposite. FBI Director James Comey talked about this in his speech this week.
每次我听到“种族不是一个因素”时，我的直觉反应是一样的。为什么要这么说？你怎么会知道？你根据什么这么说？因为有相关的科学依据——事实上，有数年的研究。而那些研究显示了相反的结果。联邦调查局局长詹姆斯·科米本周在演讲中谈到了这一点。
Much research points to the widespread existence of unconscious bias. Many people in our white majority culture have unconscious racial biases and react differently to a white face than to a black face. In fact, we all-- white and black-- carry various biases around with us.
许多研究指出，潜意识偏见广泛存在。我们白人多数文化中的许多人都有潜意识的种族偏见，对白人的面孔和黑人的面孔反应不同。事实上，我们所有人——无论白人还是黑人——都携带各种偏见。
Most of our participants associate young black men with the idea of threat.
我们大多数参与者将年轻黑人男性与“威胁”的概念联系在一起。
Psychologist Josh Correll did some of the key research the FBI director was talking about. Josh studies implicit racial biases, basically feelings that we all have about race that we may or may not be aware of. He's tested hundreds of cops. He flashes pictures of white and black men up on a computer screen. Some are holding weapons, and some are holding a wallet or a can of Coke.
心理学家乔什·科雷尔（Josh Correll）做了一些联邦调查局局长所谈论的关键研究。乔什研究内隐种族偏见，基本上是我们所有人对自己可能意识到的或可能没意识到的关于种族的感受。他测试了数百名警察。他在电脑屏幕上闪现白人和黑人男性的照片。有些拿着武器，有些拿着钱包或一罐可乐。
And you have to decide instantaneously, shoot or don't shoot. And Josh sees evidence, by how fast you do it and how many mistakes you make, of what your underlying assumptions are about black and white people-- your implicit biases.
你必须瞬间做出决定：开枪或不开枪。乔什通过你做决定的速度以及你犯错的次数，看到了你对黑人和白人的潜在假设的证据——你的内隐偏见。
For most of us, we would say things like, oh, you know, I like black people. I like black men. I don't have anything against them. I don't have any negativity toward them. That's an explicit report of an attitude.
对于我们大多数人来说，我们会说诸如，噢，你知道，我喜欢黑人。我喜欢黑人男性。我没有任何针对他们的。我没有对他们有任何负面情绪。这是对态度的明确报告。
But it goes through an editing process. When I flash a picture up on a screen and ask you to respond in 630 milliseconds, you don't have time to edit. It's like everybody has this gut response that is, oh, black means threat.
但它经过一个编辑过程。当我把一张照片闪现在屏幕上，要求你在630毫秒内做出反应时，你没有时间编辑。这就像每个人都有这种直觉反应，即：噢，黑人意味着威胁。
By everybody he means everybody-- black and white, including police. Josh's findings show that police officers are more likely to see the images of black men as threatening, even though police officers usually make the correct decision to shoot or not shoot. In fact, the rest of us-- untrained people like you and me-- do far worse than cops. We're more likely to shoot a black man with a wallet, and we're less likely to shoot a white man with a gun.
他说“每个人”是指每个人——包括黑人和白人，包括警察。乔什的研究结果表明，警察更有可能将黑人男性的图像视为威胁，尽管警察通常能做出正确的开枪或不开枪决定。事实上，我们其余的人——像你和我这样未经训练的人——表现比警察差得多。我们更有可能向拿着钱包的黑人开枪，而更不可能向拿着枪的白人开枪。
But not all cops outperform us. Josh has also given his video game test to police who work on gang units. What he's found is that the nature of policing gangs, which often means rounding up and arresting groups of young black men, does something to those officers and their decisions to shoot.
但并非所有警察都表现得比我们好。乔什还给从事帮派单位工作的警察做了视频游戏测试。他发现，处理帮派的治安工作（通常意味着围捕和逮捕一群群年轻黑人男性）对这些警察以及他们的开枪决定产生了一些影响。
When we test them, they are worse than other police. So we see bias in their response times, and we see bias in the mistakes that they make. So unlike regular cops, those special unit cops seem to be more likely to shoot an unarmed black target than an unarmed white target.
当我们测试他们时，他们比其他警察更差。所以我们在他们的反应时间里看到了偏见，在他们犯的错误里也看到了偏见。所以与普通警察不同，那些专门单位的警察似乎更有可能向手无寸铁的黑人目标开枪，而不是向手无寸铁的白人目标。
Josh says that gang units, unlike regular police, are like us. They do badly on these tests, even with all their training.
乔什说，帮派单位的警察，与普通警察不同，他们就像我们一样。即使接受了所有训练，他们在这些测试中表现也很差。
After talking to Josh, I wondered, if this research is out there, if we know this, why do we always hear race is not a problem? Are there police officers anywhere who are having a conversation about race, about how their biases might be making them worse at their jobs?
与乔什谈话后，我想，如果这些研究已经存在，如果我们知道这一点，为什么我们总是听到“种族不是个问题”？有没有什么地方的警察正在就种族问题进行对话，讨论他们的偏见可能如何使他们的工作变得更糟？
Looking around, I learned there is training for police based on this science. Implicit bias training, it's called. There's a popular two-day seminar that dozens of departments have used. So I phoned the Department of Justice, and an official told me they recommend it all the time. They've paid for 90 police departments nationwide to use it, not for all their officers, but for some. Another 150 departments have paid for it themselves.
四处打听，我了解到有基于这种科学的警察训练。这被称为“内隐偏见训练”。有一个流行的为期两天的研讨会，几十个部门已经使用过。所以我给司法部打了电话，一位官员告诉我他们一直推荐这个。他们已经为全国90个警察部门支付了费用，不是给他们所有的警察，而是给其中一部分。另外150个部门自己支付了费用。
And I asked several people at the Department of Justice, could they point me to a police force that's aggressively confronting racial bias and that's seeing results? Maybe a department that had been on the DOJ's radar for being reckless with deadly force, particularly with black men, and they'd changed for the better. A tall order, I know, but the DOJ had an answer-- Las Vegas Metropolitan Police Department.
我问了司法部的几个人，他们能否指给我看一支正在积极应对种族偏见并看到成效的警察部队？也许是一个曾经被司法部列入雷达、因动用致命武力（特别是针对黑人男性）而鲁莽行事，现在已经改过自新的部门。我知道这要求很高，但司法部有一个答案——拉斯维加斯大都会警察局（Las Vegas Metropolitan Police Department）。
So nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
I'm Sean.
我是肖恩。
Hi, Sean.
你好，肖恩。
Great to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Um, we're going to go upstairs and talk--
嗯，我们要去楼上谈谈——
My fellow producer, Sean Cole, and I visited Las Vegas Police Department together. Things were bad here for a while. Between 2007 and 2011, police shot 104 people, and 11 of those were not justified, according to the Justice Department and the police department itself.
我的同事，制片人肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）和我一起参观了拉斯维加斯警察局。这里的情况曾经很糟糕。在2007年到2011年间，警察枪杀了104人，根据司法部和警察部门本身的说法，其中11起是不正当的。
And 8 of the 11 problematic shootings were of unarmed black men. That's the number that got a lot of attention. The peak of this trend was in 2010.
在这11起有问题的枪击事件中，有8起是针对手无寸铁的黑人男性。这个数字引起了极大的关注。这一趋势的顶峰出现在2010年。
Then we had a couple things happen.
然后我们发生了一些事情。
This is Assistant Sheriff Kirk Primas. He sat down with us in his office.
这是助理警长柯克·普里马斯（Kirk Primas）。他在办公室里和我们坐下来谈话。
One is we had a couple high-profile shootings. They just sparked the interest of the community.
一是我们发生了几起高调的枪击事件。它们激发了社区的兴趣。
And the outrage of the community-- in one case, an officer shot and killed Trevon Cole, a small-time pot dealer, during a raid. Cole was 21, black, and unarmed. The cop who shot him said Cole made a threatening move toward him, but the evidence showed otherwise. Cole's family received a $1.7 million settlement. The officer involved was suspended for 40 hours.
社区的愤怒——在一个案件中，一名警官在突袭中开枪打死了特雷冯·科尔（Trevon Cole），一个小型大麻贩子。科尔21岁，黑人，手无寸铁。开枪打死他的警察说科尔对他做了一个威胁性的动作，但证据显示并非如此。科尔的家人获得了170万美元的和解金。涉事警察被停职40小时。
As an aside, this Trevon Cole was not the Trevon Cole they were after. Then, Assistant Sheriff Primas says, a local newspaper did a five-part expose.
顺便提一下，这个特雷冯·科尔并不是他们要找的那个特雷冯·科尔。然后，助理警长普里马斯说，当地一家报纸做了一篇五部分的专题报道。
On the number of officer-involved shootings in Last Vegas, a 20 year history of them. And so it was like a storm of incidents that really told us we need to do something, which we knew already.
关于拉斯维加斯警察涉案枪击事件的数量，有20年的历史记录。所以这就像一场事件的风暴，真的告诉我们我们需要做些什么，这是我们已经知道的。
So the Las Vegas Police reached out to the Department of Justice. Or it was the other way around, depending on who you ask. The DOJ did a nearly year long assessment of the department. And in 2012, they came back with their results.
所以拉斯维加斯警方联系了司法部。或者反过来，取决于你问的是谁。司法部对该部门进行了近一年的评估。2012年，他们带着结果回来了。
They said, we're great. No.
他们说，我们很棒。不。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, if you've read the report, I believe there was initially 75 recommendations.
嗯，如果你读过那份报告，我相信最初有75条建议。
75 things the department needed to do to help fix the problem of officers using deadly force inappropriately, shooting unarmed suspects, and particularly unarmed, black men. 75 things-- it's interesting to compare this with Miami Gardens, where as you heard, a lot of different things conspired to create a big problem. Here in Las Vegas, it was going to take a lot of different things to fix a big problem.
该部门需要做75件事来帮助解决警察不当使用致命武力、枪杀手无寸铁的嫌疑人（特别是手无寸铁的黑人男性）的问题。75件事——将此与迈阿密花园进行比较很有趣，正如你听到的，很多不同的事情合谋制造了一个大问题。在这里拉斯维加斯，需要很多不同的事情来解决一个大问题。
And here's what strikes you when you look at this list of 75 suggestions. For one, a lot of them seem obvious. Recommendation 22, the department should implement restrictions on when officers may shoot at moving vehicles. Recommendation number 36, supervisors should be trained on the new use of force policy before they go ahead and train other people on the new use of force policy. I'm paraphrasing.
当你查看这75条建议时，有些事情会引起你的注意。首先，其中很多看起来很明显。建议22：部门应该限制警察何时可以向移动的车辆开枪。建议36：主管在训练其他人执行新的武力使用政策之前，应该先接受新武力使用政策的培训。我是在转述。
Speaking of, more than one third of these recommendations include some form of the word training or training-- de-escalation training, advanced training in procedural justice. Plus, the DOJ recommends organizational changes and changes in the way that use of force cases are investigated. And this would all seem pretty standard if it weren't for how the Las Vegas Police responded to these suggestions-- which is to say, stunningly well.
说到这一点，这些建议中有超过三分之一包含某种形式的“训练”或“训练”一词——降级冲突训练、程序公正的高级训练。此外，司法部建议组织变革和改变调查武力使用案件的方式。如果不是因为拉斯维加斯警察对这些建议的反应——也就是出人意料的好——所有这些看起来都很标准。
They're like the over-achieving star pupil in the class. The recommendations were voluntary. They didn't have to act on any of them, but Assistant Sheriff Primas told us that the department had already implemented 47 of the 75 recommendations before the DOJ even got around to suggesting them officially.
他们就像班上成绩超群的明星学生。这些建议是自愿的。他们没必要采纳其中任何一条，但助理警长普里马斯告诉我们，在司法部正式建议之前，该部门已经实施了75条建议中的47条。
These days in Las Vegas, each and every officer involved shooting is investigated by no fewer than five committees. Assistant Sheriff Primas told us that on one of the committees the civilian members-- that is, people like you and me-- can actually outvote four to three the police members on what direction an investigation should go in. And as a result of all of this, officers who are involved in unjustified shootings are punished more than they were before. And by more than before, I mean they weren't before.
如今在拉斯维加斯，每一桩警察涉案枪击事件都由不少于五个委员会调查。助理警长普里马斯告诉我们，其中一个委员会的平民成员——也就是说，像你我这样的人——实际上可以在调查方向上以四比三的投票结果战胜警察成员。作为所有这一切的结果，那些卷入不正当枪击事件的警官受到的惩罚比以前更多了。说到“比以前多”，我的意思是以前根本就没有惩罚。
I'm Deputy Chief Kirk Primas. This morning at 12:08 hours--
我是副局长柯克·普里马斯。今天早上12点08分——
Also, every time there's an officer-involved shooting in Las Vegas now, an official, sometimes Primas himself, shows up at the scene and explains on video what happened. And then they put the video up on YouTube just to be as transparent as possible.
此外，现在拉斯维加斯每次发生警察涉案枪击事件时，一名官员（有时是普里马斯本人）都会出现在现场，并在视频中解释发生了什么。然后他们把视频放到YouTube上，尽可能地透明。
One officer discharged their firearm. A suspect was hit several times and ran into the bathroom, where she locked the door.
一名警官开枪射击。一名嫌疑人被击中多次，跑进洗手间，在那里锁上了门。
And all of these solutions, they worked. Last year, there were zero unjustified shootings by police in Las Vegas. And all of these solutions, they worked. Last year, there were zero unjustified shootings by police in Las Vegas.
而所有这些解决方案，它们都奏效了。去年，拉斯维加斯发生的警察不正当枪击事件为零。所有这些解决方案，它们都奏效了。去年，拉斯维加斯发生的警察不正当枪击事件为零。
But the key reform that Assistant Sheriff Primas has focused on, the one he says is the leading reason that the department has been able to cut down on officer-involved shootings, is number 28 on the DOJ recommendation list.
但助理警长普里马斯重点关注的关键改革，也是他所说的该部门能够减少警察涉案枪击事件的主要原因，是司法部建议列表上的第28条。
We started a reality-based training program.
我们开始了一个基于现实的训练计划。
A reality-based based training program.
一个基于现实的训练计划。
And really what that simply is is we took scenarios, our own department scenarios--
真的，这很简单，就是我们采用了场景，我们自己部门的场景——
So actual events that Las Vegas cops have actually been through.
也就是拉斯维加斯警察真正经历过的实际事件。
--and recreated them--
——并重现它们——
In a vacant lot with fellow police officers pretending to be criminals.
在一个空地上，让同事警察假扮罪犯。
And we made them as realistic as possible, to expose them to the situations where they had to make deadly-force decisions, or force decisions.
我们让它们尽可能真实，使他们暴露在必须做出致命武力决定或武力决定的情况下。
So real cop cars, real police radios. The bullets are fake, though.
所以有真的警车，真的警用电台。不过子弹是假的。
let me see your hands and get out of the vehicle!
让我看到你的手，从车里出来！
Robyn and I watched a couple of these drills. In this one, six officers respond to a pretend carjacking. None of them have been told what's going to happen, so they have to just respond like they would in real life. Now, again, the point of this training is to figure out alternative solutions instead of using force, instead of firing your weapon.
罗宾和我看了几次这种演习。在这次演习中，六名警察应对一次假劫车事件。他们都没被告知会发生什么，所以他们必须像在现实生活中那样做出反应。现在，再次重申，这种训练的重点是找出替代解决方案，而不是使用武力，而不是开枪。
Sir!
先生！
You may have heard this buzzword recently, de-escalation-- basically, calming a situation down before it hits a boiling point. This is what de-escalation sounds like.
你可能最近听到过这个流行词，“降级冲突”——基本上是在事情达到临界点之前让局势平静下来。这就是降级冲突听起来的样子。
gonna shoot. Step out. You haven't done very much wrong right now. You're making it work for yourself.
要开枪了。走出来。你现在没做错什么。你正在让事情变得可控。
I come out, you ain't gonna shoot me, man?
我出来，你不会开枪打我吧，伙计？
gonna shoot. Put your hands up when you come out the door, straight up in the air.
要开枪了。出来时把手举起来，笔直举向空中。
The fake suspect gets out and walks backwards toward the police, who fake arrest him. No guns were fired. This was policing through persuasion. Their trainer said they did really well.
假嫌疑人出来，向警察倒退，警察假装逮捕他。没有开枪。这是通过说服进行治安管理。他们的教练说他们做得很好。
keep stepping back now. Come back. Stop right there. Walk back--
继续向后退。退回来。停在那儿。退后——
But the DOJ recommendation I was most interested in was number 4.2.1. "Las Vegas Police should provide its commanders, supervisors, and officers with advanced, specialized training in fair and impartial policing." In other words, implicit bias training.
但我最感兴趣的司法部建议是4.2.1。“拉斯维加斯警察应该为指挥官、主管和警官提供高级的、专门的‘公平与公正警务’培训。”换句话说，内隐偏见训练。
I was surprised to learn it was one of the last reforms, of the many reforms, the Vegas police tackled. I'd assumed bias training would be one of the first things any department would do. But classes just began in October. Which means they made huge progress --they bought the number of unjust police shootings to zero --months before they asked individual officers to sit down and think about their own biases.
我很惊讶地发现这是拉斯维加斯警察处理的众多改革中的最后几项改革之一。我以为偏见训练会是任何部门做的第一件事。但课程直到十月才开始。这意味着他们在要求个别警官坐下来思考自己的偏见之前，就已经取得了巨大进展——把不当警察枪击事件降到了零。
There were no classes scheduled when we visited. But we got to talk to a few of the instructors about what they teach, the most candid of whom was Training Officer Marla Stevens. She's third-generation police, been with the force for 15 years. She says cops can be a rough crowd, a really rough crowd, especially if they're at a class that's required and that has the word bias in it. So she's strategic about how she kicks things off. She says she starts her class by saying, I understand some of you don't want to be here, and I get that.
我们去的时候没有安排课程。但我们确实和几位讲师谈了谈他们教的内容，其中最坦诚的是训练警官玛拉·史蒂文斯（Marla Stevens）。她是第三代警察，已经在警队工作了15年。她说警察可能是一群粗鲁的人，非常粗鲁，特别是如果他们参加的课程是强制性的，而且名字里带有“偏见”这个词。所以她在开始时采取了战略。她说她开始上课时会说：我理解你们中有些人不想待在这里，我懂。
I talk about how we got to this place. And I tell them, you know, this started with the officer-involved shootings that we had in 2011. The fact is, did we shoot more unarmed black men than we did white? Absolutely, we did. And we put those numbers up there and show them to our officers and say, these are the stats. You can't argue with those numbers.
我谈论我们是如何走到这一步的。我告诉他们，你知道，这一切始于我们在2011年发生的警察涉案枪击事件。事实是，我们枪杀的无辜黑人男性是否比白人多？当然，确实如此。我们把这些数字放在那里，向我们的警察展示并说，这些就是统计数据。你无法与这些数字争辩。
From there, she eases them to the concept of bias, baby steps, first acknowledging biases nobody finds shameful or controversial. She says her class is filled with truck-loving men, so they talk about the thing that divides them-- Chevy or Ford.
从那里，她引导他们进入偏见的概念，循序渐进，首先承认没人觉得羞耻或有争议的偏见。她说她的班里坐满了爱车男，所以他们谈论分裂他们的事情——雪佛兰还是福特。
And start the whole fight in the audience of which truck is better.
在观众中引发了一场关于哪种卡车更好的全面争论。
Next step, she nudges them toward more personal biases, talks about her own. And then she gets to race.
下一步，她引导他们走向更个人的偏见，谈论她自己的偏见。然后她谈到种族。
And if you can't be honest enough with yourself to say, why am I really stopping this guy? Am I stopping this guy because I just watched him jaywalk and there's something not right here? Or are you stopping him because he's a black guy in a white neighborhood? Be honest with yourself. Ask yourself those questions. And if you have that bias, you need to recognize it. That's the first thing, is recognizing that you have it.
如果你不能对自己诚实地说，我为什么要拦下这个家伙？我是拦下他仅仅因为我刚看到他乱穿马路，还是因为他在白人社区里是个黑人？对自己诚实。问问自己这些问题。如果你有这种偏见，你需要承认它。第一件事就是承认你有它。
I had been wondering how forceful these trainings were. These were hard questions she was forcing the cops in her classes to face.
我一直想知道这些培训有多强制。这些是她强迫班上的警察去面对的尖锐问题。
And if you can't fix it, then maybe you're not in the right line of work. You know, maybe this isn't for you. I'm not afraid to say that to somebody, either.
如果你不能修正它，那么也许你并不适合这份工作。你知道，也许这不适合你。我也不会害怕对别人说出这一点。
Really?
真的吗？
Look, I'm at an age now, I just don't care. I mean, what's right is right, and what's wrong is wrong. And if you want to sit around and say, oh, this is all [BLEEP], well, maybe this isn't the place for you.
看，我已经到了这个年纪，我不在乎了。我是说，对的就是对的，错的就是错的。如果你想坐在这里说，噢，这全是废话，那么，也许这不适合你。
The takeaway from the class, what I liked most about when they were teaching us about biases, is having a bias isn't being racist.
从课上学到的东西，关于他们教我们偏见的部分，我最喜欢的是：有偏见并不等于种族主义。
This is officer Brett Brosnahan. He's been on the force for six years and took the implicit bias class. He talked with Sean.
这是布雷特·布罗斯纳汉（Brett Brosnahan）警官。他在警队工作了六年，参加了内隐偏见课程。他与肖恩交谈过。
Having a bias isn't being sexist. It's none of those things. Biased is, you know, maybe I've stopped three or four guys that look exactly like this man. And every time I've stopped them, I found guns or dope on them. So you just put the trait from the person that was guilty onto the person that's innocent.
有偏见并不等于性别歧视。它什么都不是。偏见是，你知道，也许我拦下了三四个看起来和这个人一模一样的人。而每次我拦下他们时，我都从他们身上搜出了枪或毒品。所以你就把那个有罪之人的特征加到了无辜之人的身上。
And does that, I mean, does that make you feel bad when you realize that you think that? Do you know what I mean, like about yourself?
而且，我是说，当你意识到你有这种想法时，你会感觉糟糕吗？我的意思是，关于你自己？
It is. It's scary because it's not fair. It's not fair for me to assume that this guy's going to have the same background. I mean, he might be the CEO of a company, just out for a walk, and didn't want to walk to the crosswalk. I don't know.
是的。这很可怕，因为它不公平。我假设这家伙有同样的背景是不公平的。我是说，他可能是某家公司的CEO，只是出来散散步，不想走过人行横道。我不知道。
These days, whenever Brett rolls up on a situation-- a traffic stop or questioning a suspect, whatever it is-- he says he tries to keep his mind totally open, thinking, this could be anyone. The class also made him reassess something that happened to him that's now legend at the department. It actually happened a month before he took the training, and it was horrible.
这些天，每当布雷特遇到某种情况——交通拦截或盘问嫌疑人，不管是什么——他说他尽量让自己的思想完全开放，想着，“这可能是任何人。”这门课程也让他重新审视了一件发生在他身上，现在已成为警局传奇的事情。它实际上发生在他参加培训的前一个月，非常可怕。
Last June on a Sunday morning, two of Brett's fellow officers were shot to death in a pizza place on the north side of the city. Brett responded to the scene not long after. The other customers, of course, were freaking out, yelling, he went that way. He went that way, meaning the shooter. Brett figured it might be a revenge killing of some sort, either against cops in general or these two officers in specific.
去年6月的一个周日上午，布雷特的两个同事在城市北边的一家披萨店被枪杀。布雷特在事发后不久赶到了现场。当然，其他顾客都吓坏了，大叫着：他往那边走了！他往那边走了！意思是枪手。布雷特心想这可能是某种报复性杀戮，要么是针对普通警察，要么是针对这两名警官。
In that area, I mean, it's a high gang environment. There's a lot of gang members there. And--
在那个地区，我是说，那是个高犯罪环境。那里有很多帮派成员。而且——
Did you think, male, female, black, white, anything like that?
你想过男性、女性、黑人、白人，类似的事情吗？
Male, probably black or Hispanic. I mean, northeast area part of Las Vegas, it's a large black and Hispanic population. So, you know, you go with the odds.
男性，可能是黑人或西班牙裔。我是说，拉斯维加斯东北部地区，那里有大量黑人和西班牙裔人口。所以，你知道，你就照概率来判断。
Brett takes off on foot in the direction everyone's pointing and eventually ends up at a Walmart. Customers, employees, everyone is flooding out of the store screaming. So, now, this isn't just an isolated shooting of two cops. This is an active shooter in a crowded, public place. And at this point, the color of the suspect in Brett's mind changes from black or Hispanic to white.
布雷特沿着每个人指的方向步行追去，最终到达了一家沃尔玛。顾客、员工，每个人都尖叫着从店里涌出。所以，现在，这不仅仅是两名警察被孤立枪击的事件。这是在拥挤、公共场所发生的活跃枪手事件。在这一点上，布雷特脑海中嫌疑人的肤色从黑人或西班牙裔变成了白人。
Brett knows about active-shooter situations. He trains other officers in how to deal with these cases. Columbine, Aurora, Sandy Hook-- when Brett thinks active shooter, he thinks young white male. The whole story is too long to tell here, but in short, Brett ultimately finds himself in an empty Walmart getting ready to ambush the gunman in the automotive section.
布雷特了解活跃枪手的情况。他训练其他警察如何处理这些案件。科伦拜恩、奥罗拉、桑迪胡克——当布雷特想到活跃枪手时，他想到的是年轻白人男性。整个故事在这里说不完，但简而言之，布雷特最终发现自己在一个空荡荡的沃尔玛里，准备在汽车区伏击持枪歹徒。
It's a young white male, semi-automatic pistol in his hand. He doesn't see Brett.
那是一个年轻的白人男性，手里拿着半自动手枪。他没看到布雷特。
And I start to make my final turn to get a good angle on him. And I come almost face to face with a female, probably four or five feet away. And, keep in mind, all this now is happening in fractions of a second. But my first thought is, why is she in here? And then I look more at her and I'm like, she's not a victim. She's not a customer. She wants to be exactly where she is right now.
我开始做最后一次转弯以获得一个好的角度。我几乎和一个女性面对面了，大约只有四五英尺远。而且，请记住，现在这一切都发生在几分之一秒内。但我的第一个想法是：她为什么在这里？然后我更多地看着她，心想：她不是受害者。她不是顾客。她想确切地待在现在的那个位置。
In all the commotion, people yelling and pointing and telling Brett where the shooter was, no one ever mentioned there were two of them. Brett and the woman exchanged gunfire from four or five feet away. Miraculously, she missed him. Brett hit her in the shoulder.
在所有的骚乱中，人们大喊大叫、指点并告诉布雷特枪手在哪里，没有人提到有两个人。布雷特和那个女人从四五英尺外互相开枪。奇迹般地，她没打中他。布雷特击中了她的肩膀。
He ran out of the store and let another team of officers take over. After a firefight, the male shooter was dead. His wife shot herself in the head. So this was what was on Brett's mind when he went into the implicit bias training class a month later.
他跑出店外，让另一组警察接手。经过一场交火，男枪手死了。他的妻子朝自己的头上开了一枪。所以这就是布雷特一个月后去参加内隐偏见培训班时脑子里想的事情。
When they started to explain that these biases aren't based on being racist, they're not based on being sexist, they're just based on our experience, I was like, oh my gosh. I've been teaching this for years. Active shooters are white guys. Active shooters, when we role play, are white officers that act as the suspect.
当他们开始解释这些偏见不是基于种族主义、不是基于性别歧视，它们只是基于我们的经验时，我心想：噢，天哪。我已经教了这套很多年了。活跃枪手是白人。当我们进行角色扮演时，活跃枪手是扮演嫌疑人的白人警察。
We never throw a female in the mix. So I had that aha moment. Wow, that's what happened to me. I thought that this woman wasn't going to be a threat to me and let her remain as she was a little bit longer than I probably should have.
我们从不让女性参与其中。所以我有了那个“啊哈”时刻。哇，这就是发生在我身上的事。我以为这个女人不会对我构成威胁，让她保持现状的时间可能比我应该做的要长。
It was like a real-life version of the computer test that researchers do in the lab. White female, armed-- shoot or don't shoot? And Brett paused for just a second.
这就像研究人员在实验室里做的电脑测试的现实版本。白人女性，武装——开枪还是不开枪？布雷特迟疑了一秒钟。
I asked my police officer friend in New York, the one I watched the Eric Garner video with, if she thought some sort of bias training would be valuable for the NYPD. And she literally rolled her eyes and said it was insulting to tell her she didn't know how to talk to black people. Roughly half of her coworkers at the NYPD aren't white.
我问我在纽约的警察朋友——那个和我一起看埃里克·加纳视频的人——她是否认为某种偏见训练对纽约警局有价值。她字面意思地翻了个白眼，说告诉她她不知道如何与黑人交谈是侮辱她。她在纽约警局的同事中，大约有一半不是白人。
The thing she felt way more urgently was how hard the past months have been, ever since Eric Garner's death, the hardest for her in all of her years at the NYPD. She says crowds form when she makes arrests more than ever. It feels more dangerous. She feels like she's risking her life every day for a city of people who hate her. She feels alone and threatened.
她感受更强烈的是过去几个月过得有多艰难，自从埃里克·加纳死后，这是她在纽约警局多年来最困难的一年。她说现在当她逮捕人时，形成的人群比以往任何时候都多。感觉更危险了。她觉得她每天都在为一个憎恨她的城市的人民冒着生命危险。她感到孤独和受到威胁。
And you know, I have to point out to our classes, too, is the public biased towards us? Sure they are.
你知道，我也必须指出我的班级，公众对我们有偏见吗？当然有。
Again, Marla Stevens, one of the implicit bias instructors. She says lots of cops have this feeling my friend has, and it's actually useful in her class, something to talk about.
再次重申，玛拉·史蒂文斯，内隐偏见讲师之一。她说很多警察都有我朋友这种感觉，这实际上在她的课上很有用，是有话可谈的内容。
Do they have stereotypes about us? They most certainly do. Which, you know, it's aggravating, too, so turn that around. You know, if you don't like that being thrown on you by people that don't know you, how do you think that people on the street feel when you prejudge them and you don't them either? It's the same thing. And it's like beating your head against the wall, trying to get both sides to understand this concept. You know? It really is.
他们对我们有刻板印象吗？他们肯定有。这，你知道，也很恼人，所以把它反过来看看。你知道，如果你不喜欢被不认识你的人这样对待，你怎么认为街上的人在你预先评判他们而你也不认识他们时会有什么感觉？这是一回事。就像对着墙撞头，试图让双方都理解这个概念。你知道吗？真的是这样。
This week, the FBI director, James Comey, talked about this exact problem of not being able to see each other. Everything I've been hoping a police chief would say after one of these incidents, he said to police. He told them, basically, I'm one of you. My grandfather was a cop. I have great affection and respect for police officers. And, he said, there's nothing more American than the conversation we need to have now about race.
本周，联邦调查局局长詹姆斯·科米谈到了这种无法看清彼此的确切问题。我一直希望警察局长在这些事件之一后会说的所有话，他都对警察说了。他基本上告诉他们：我是你们中的一员。我的祖父是警察。我对警察有着深厚的感情和尊重。而且，他说，没有比我们现在需要进行的关于种族的谈话更符合美国精神的事了。
I am descended from Irish immigrants. A century ago, the Irish knew well how American society and law enforcement viewed them-- as drunks, ruffians, and criminals. The Irish had some tough times, but little compares to the experience on our soil of black Americans.
我是爱尔兰移民的后裔。一个世纪前，爱尔兰人很清楚美国社会和执法部门如何看待他们——醉鬼、暴徒和罪犯。爱尔兰人经历过一些艰难时期，但很少有能与美国黑人在我们这片土地上的经历相比。
That experience should be part of every American's consciousness. And we, especially those of us who enjoy the privilege that comes with being the majority, must confront the biases that are an inescapable part of the human condition. We must speak the truth about our shortcomings as law enforcement and fight to get better. We simply must speak to each other honestly about all these hard truths.
那种经历应该成为每个美国人意识的一部分。而我们，特别是那些享有身为多数群体所带来的特权的人，必须正视那些身为人类不可避免的偏见。我们必须诚实地谈论我们作为执法部门的缺点，并努力去变得更好。我们仅仅需要诚实地就所有这些艰苦的真相互相交流。
Well, our program was produced today by Sean Cole with Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Editing by Joel Lovell.
嗯，我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔制作，斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、查纳·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。编辑是乔尔·洛维尔（Joel Lovell）。
Production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
制作帮助来自西蒙·阿德勒（Simon Adler）。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责我们的网站。埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）为我们的节目发掘故事。研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He wants you to know, he's down.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他想让你知道，他是支持的。
Oh, you know, I like black people. I like black men. I don't have anything against them.
噢，你知道，我喜欢黑人。我喜欢黑人男性。我没有任何针对他们的。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。